George Wilson in your new book and the
introduction you open up with the first
sentence the world changed for the
United States and its army in 1966 why
did you open up that one because I think
it really did change dramatically 1966
was the year we practically doubled our
troops on the ground and we stopped
pretending we were there to advise the
South Vietnamese Army and we put enough
troops in to do the operations ourselves
so it became an American war in 1966
because we had the troops to do what the
commanders really really wanted to do
see secretly anyhow which was have the
Americans run their own show rather just
be sprinkled among South Vietnamese
units and that changed a lot of things
the title of your new book mud soldier's
life inside the new American army is
about what it's about today's grunt
today soldier who would go out on the
point if we ever got in in the next war
it's the infantryman the guy who's
always cold he's always hungry
whether it's peace or war and he's the
first guy to get killed and he's the
first guy to fight and it's a thin red
line that defends our country and all
but a sudden nuclear holocaust so it's
the spear point of the American army and
I thought that that part of it was
important and we ought to take a look at
it
how'd you write it well I wrote it by
what I like to call is the participatory
journalism I went down to Fort Benning
and went through basic training and
advanced advanced individual infantry
training with this company of troops and
then when they went to Fort Riley to
report to their unit I went with him
there and then when they fought the
Russians in California and mock warfare
I stayed within the desert for two weeks
to see how they did how do these
apprentice informants acquit themselves
and then I looked them up a year later
and said oK you've had a year in the
Army what were your hopes and fears and
did the army live up to them and are you
better are you worse how was this unique
passage from teenager to soldier from
soldier to infantryman how did it go how
did you actually what suppose a
timeframe
they did this how many months well I
went down to I went I went went down to
Fort Benning in 1987 this summer of 87
when the kids got off the bus with their
long hair and their gold earrings and
the drill sergeants started snapping at
him and shaking him up so it was the
summer of 87 and then the fall of 88 we
went to Fort Riley where they reported
to their unit to be active duty regular
line integer them an army gave you what
kind of access complete access the deal
was that I would only do it if I didn't
have a lieutenant lock step of me and
listening in on interviews and I could
go where I please and talk to them when
I wanted to as long as I didn't know
interfere with their training or do
something stupid like getting in their
way on the rifle range so I have to say
the army it was good to its word and
they let me be kind of the invisible
chronicler all through their training
and their duty and made no efforts to
stop me from talking to the kids
you worked full-time for the Washington
Post as a pentagon correspondent during
that period when you were writing this
did you also do pieces for the post yes
I did about three pieces called the new
GI and the deal with the post is that
they would let me go off duty for them
and spend full time with this army unit
providing periodically I would give them
a a look at these new soldiers and I did
so so it worked out pretty well
what happenings in Georgia yes Columbus
Georgia what happened when you were down
up close looking at these young folks
getting ready for the army that you
least expected at least expected the
drill sergeants to welcome me I thought
you know I would be the intruder you
know as a reporter you're not exactly
welcomed at military bases to start with
but with drill sergeants they consider
themselves the real authoritarian figure
and
they run their own show and I thought
I'd never be able to defrost these guys
that I would always be someone getting
in their act and they would resent it
and I found just the opposite that
everybody likes to to talk to some
neutral corner and have a listener and
after I was there a couple weeks and
they saw that I wasn't getting in the
way or showboating they started to tell
me about their problems of trying to
shape up young teenagers and being
overworked and divorces and I ended up
being good friends with a number of the
drill sergeants and that was a big
surprise to me I thought they would be
the hardest nuts to crack and they
turned out to be a real regular guys did
you withhold anything that you learned
from the book on purpose because it
would embarrass or would have fists yeah
yes I did I did not use last names of
guys who try to commit suicide because
they couldn't hack army training I
didn't see the point of ruining their
civilian careers the incident is
described in a very level the reader and
I say I'm calling this guy so-and-so
which is not his real name frankly a
couple of kids who attempted suicide
wanted their names used they they wanted
some some reason for their sacrifice in
their view but I thought when they got a
little older they might represent that
and regret it so I have not identified
some of the characters in here who got
in real trouble what's your motivation
for writing the book hey I wanted to
take a look at whether the Army is
living up to its advertising be all you
can be be I thought it would be really
interesting you get back down in the mud
after hearing the theoretical in
Washington I kind of like to do this
periodically as you know I went out in
an aircraft carrier for seven months and
I I really relate to the grunts whether
they be sailors or soldiers and if
you're away from the to lone you kind of
lose touch what's real in the military
did you put fatigues on no I didn't I
debated about that the army kind of
wanted me to and I said well I'm not
going to pretend to be something I'm not
yeah I figured if I put fatigues on I
should do all the push-ups do everything
they did and I wasn't going to kid
myself and go through basic training
again I did that once and I also wanted
to be a neutral
corner and it turned out I think the
right decision because I wore field
khakis this regular old field khakis in
a jungle hat and the kids when I was
there felt kind of reassured that you
know they had kind of an uncle figure
that when they're off duty they would
tell me about their homesickness and
stuff they couldn't tell their peers
because everybody has to be macho in the
infantry so I was kind of a kind of an
unexpected priest without portfolio out
in the field with these kids and not
having a uniform enable them to know
where I was and kind of you know I was
there and I wasn't one of the bad guys
if you will kids of your own yes I have
a son who could have been in the
military he's of that age and I have a
daughter did did you make such close
friends of some of these kids that you
still are in contact with him they write
me frequently and I still worry about
him and they become like second songs
sure what's the supercarrier right was
that the Kennedy that was the Kennedy
right
USS Kennedy you were out there for seven
months you wrote a book called
supercarrier 1983 right right became a
television show true I didn't make it as
a television say what was the reason
well my theory is that supercarrier it
could have been change it turned into a
a mash kind of series because there's so
much human emotion locked up in the
walls of a ship and it's a very intense
experience that cannot be duplicated on
land just as the experience of mash
can't be duplicated in the hospital you
have to have it inside that tent but
Hollywood in my view decided they were
going to be Hollywood and we had to get
into drugs and women and a gun play and
all the things that don't happen on a
carer so by the second show the the core
audience that people know anything about
the military and anything about the Navy
knew this was just a sham and tuned out
what's the or is there any major
difference between the Navy sailor and
the mud soldier not in his human
qualities or his background but in his
interest the mud soldier doesn't want to
go to sea in most cases and
not as technically oriented the Sailor
kind of gets into running an airplane
running a ship whereas the mud soldier
wants to be a Rambo run up and down
hills shoot guns The Midnight Stalker
it's a different kind of motivation did
the Navy and the army treat you
differently the army officers were less
suspicious of me than the Navy officers
on the ship
partly because I had already written
supercarrier a number of them had read
it and figured I'd tell it like it is
but the other thing that's probably more
important is that the Army is so
appreciative when somebody bothers to
take a look at their soldiers because
it's not the most glamorous of the
services and they feel they've been
somewhat eclipsed by the Flyboys and
people who have more dramatic activities
a plain old mud soldier is kind of an
orphan
so they appreciate somebody taking the
time to look at what they were doing and
I guess I'd have to say they they were
they welcomed me a little more one of
the things I'm looking for it right now
I'm sure you can remember that kind of
surprising when I read the introduction
is the number of soldiers I thought it
was much larger than that for some
reason how many American army soldiers
are there today there's about seven
hundred and seventy-one thousand in the
United States Army total that's half the
number that we had in Vietnam at the
height of the war so we have a small
army my point is if it's gonna be small
it ought to be good and they've got the
money they've got the equipment now
we've got to manage this resource namely
the soldier and one of my regrets is we
don't lean far enough toward this new
volunteer soldier we still regard him as
a draftee wants three hots and a cot and
don't realize you have to keep the light
at the end of his tunnel you have to
make this kid believe that he's being
all he can be he gets turned off and he
goes right back to some of his bad
habits in civilian life and it's a
management challenge just as teaching
the arithmetic is a management challenge
in a high school if you give up on being
a good teacher in there I mean you could
lose these kids I want to show the
audience something yeah you you list in
the back the graduates you have a little
column here called the graduates and
we'll see it here in just a second as
soon as we can get a close shot of this
come on
their mark let's take a look at who are
these graduates they are they are the
invisible Patriots they're the kids that
volunteer for the infantry even though
they don't have to do there's no draft
today let me interrupt because I don't
want to lose this yeah one of the
reasons I wanted our audience to see
this is it 18 19 20 21 18 18 18 oh and
if you go over here on the next page you
go on for how many are listed on this do
you remember George there would be about
120 17 18 and all that I mean is that
the average age of PBS the other kids
right out of high school they usually
come from a town where it's a dead end
and going to the army as a way up they
don't want to work at McDonald's they
want to they don't want to go to the
local factory some of them had offers of
college scholarships because of the
wrestling ability for instance but
they're sick of book work and they want
to go be a Rambo so they they joined the
Army Infantry for adventure and and
basic the army delivers but in the
regular units it's too boring for them
and the kids get disillusioned how long
do they sign up for well it's 2 to 4
years of its its selective in the Army's
in the Army's interest sometimes they'll
accept two years enlistees and sometimes
they won't but basically most of these
kids signed up for four years what's
their pay when they start they get about
$800 a month something like that how's
that track with what they would make if
they were outside well when you count
everything money is not the problem they
do they do better than they do on the
civilian market for instance a couple of
these guys that I got to know well join
the army because their wives were
pregnant and they realized they were
facing hospital bills they couldn't pay
and the army would take care of that
they didn't know whether they get laid
off from the job they had so the
security the army plus the adventure is
appealing to a good part of
non-establishment America these are not
the guys who have the chance to go to
prep school in most cases in college
they have they have their working
America how many people that apply for
the army get in
well I don't know exactly the
percentages you have to pass an entrance
test and some months you may get in with
a low score because they're accepting a
given number what they call category
fours other months they may not need
bodies to fill spaces so you have to get
a higher score to be category one or two
so it varies month by month but a high
school average student who is good
physically could almost guarantee
getting in the army how many of them
react at the end of their tour it the
percentage again vary but I would guess
right now about twenty percent he's that
number low or high compared to what it
used to be when we had a draft I think
it's better than during the draft it's
that's a good question the draft soldier
didn't want to be there and as soon as
he could he got out so I would be
surprised if say in the 60s and 70s the
reenlistment rate was anywhere near as
high as between twenty thirty five
percent like it is today what's known
today as some of the better duty
stations for somebody in the army well
it used to be exciting to go overseas
and a lot of guys join the army thinking
it's going to be glamorous to go to
Germany and go to distant places but now
they have found out that the economies
of Europe are more expensive than around
home so Germany is no longer glamorous
to these kids oh very often they have no
choice so I was surprised to find out
that when they get a little more
experience with what army life is like
and how expensive Germany is that they
look for bases around home so that they
can continue to be in uniform but they
could get the support structure at home
like if you're from California you might
like Ford or it if you were from the
south you might rather go to Fort
Benning but these soldiers are not the
From Here to Eternity bums with no roots
at all they come in wanting to better
themselves they do have alternatives so
if they can stay in the Army and get a
trade and see themselves
in Seng they'll work out a way to put
down roots raise family and nobody lives
in the barracks anymore for instance
after the first couple months of
training and you go to your regular unit
very very few live in the barracks they
get married young and then they get
apartments in town or trailers so you
don't have if you if your mind's eye
picture of an army is everybody living
together as single men in barracks and
falling out in formation you're in for a
surprise the barrack is cut up into
little little rooms it's more like a
college dormitory and a fair number of
soldiers have outside activities that
interest them they don't always go down
and drink beer at the rec hall or the
bowling alley it's somewhat a blending
of civilian and military right right on
a base do you think
after spending all this time thinking
about the mud so do you think that the
mud soldier will ever be used again in a
serious way by the United States I think
yes I think we always are going to need
mud soldiers my view is that an American
rifle company is our best high-tech
weapon because it seems to me the least
likely war is that the United States the
Soviet Union gonna blow each other up
with sudden nuclear strikes that to me
takes Mad Men on both sides but I can
see a lot of problems in the third world
where being able to get there with a
rifle company would be great deterrence
and if need be you might have to take on
some number of bad guys so who are you
going to send we're going to send either
the Marines or the infantry you're not
going to send the b-2 stealth bomber
which costs over half a billion each
you're not going to send missiles you're
gonna send these kids and if you look at
the third world there's lots of trouble
spots what's the difference between a
u.s. Marine and the u.s. infantry well
if if you're if you're marine the
dog-faced soldier I can't do anything if
you're a
infantryman while the Marine is a
jarhead basically they do much the same
thing the Marines have a little
different philosophy on there
fireteams for instance but I think
American soldiers are American soldiers
whether they be Marines or infantryman
and I have no worries about them running
and letting us down I've got some
worries about whether they're well
enough lead seems to me we've gotten
into this management syndrome where you
give a guy a rifle company for a year or
a year and a half and then you put him
in a staff job and then you sent him to
Charm School you can't get good leading
troops and winning battles with all this
turbulence at the top how would you
change that I'd do a lot of things first
thing I'd do I'd make every officer who
got out of West Point or ROTC go through
basic training with troops we'd where no
one Signet he'd get no favors
he would do the same thing the kids he's
going to command do that way they would
finally come to understand that these
kids have dreams they want to be better
they have expectations
they're not just automata too many of
today's officers are yuppies
they just want to run their unit and
then go on to a staff job and advance
their career to be army chief of staff I
want them to get to know their soldiers
better and the only way I know how to
make him get to know their soldiers
better is to merge them for six weeks
with these kids so they know what
they're about then go ahead and and
redraw the fire break and have the
separation from basic training forward
they couldn't serve at the same young
man that they went through basic
training with could be they could end up
commanding him further down the road but
chances are they would not by the time
that they were up senior enough to
command a company would be a new crop
it'd be the same kind of kid and they
know what they would know it made him
tick but it would not be the very guy
they slept in the barracks okay so I
mean it's a technical question you
couldn't walk right out of there and the
command there no I don't think that's
necessary or desirable that's one thing
I do the other thing I do is I'd go back
to Shai Meyers theory he was army chief
of staff and he said that he wanted
people to command rifle units and
battalions and companies for three years
he didn't want this in-and-out stuff and
we've gotten back to the year and a half
two or the 12-month tour and you know
the new guy comes in he takes over a
rifle company he wants to make a record
for himself he wears out the kids and
the new guy comes in tries to do the
same thing
the sergeant's are left there for three
years or more why not the officers
basically what are those sergeants think
of the officer in general they think the
officers are too much the micromanagers
and I came to agree fact I bring the
polo ponies back I think they brought
the polo ponies back the officer would
be so darn busy getting ready for the
Saturday polo match that they leave the
soldiers and sergeants alone so the
sergeant's could get back to running
their units and the officers would do
more big picture managing instead of
doing the sergeant's work all the time
you really came away with some strong
feelings yeah I came you know the army
is a great institution it's helping
thousands and thousands of young people
it's the best social betterment
institution we have I just want to be
all it can be and there's a lot of room
for improvement and my biggest regret is
we have this golden moment here where
you got high quality kids willing to
serve the country in peacetime and we're
we're not making the most of it we're
not leaning toward this kid enough we're
not making it interesting we're not
making it fun somehow the North Harris
got gotten to be a workaholics I don't
seem wrong working a half a day and
having the kids play baseball or
basketball or do something physical it's
fun but the new Cinderella must keep
them out in the field to check this
block that block and whether they're
learning anything or not keep them out
in the rain and I just think we would
have lighten up and make it fun all
right the call comes from the president
he wants X troops in a hot spot in the
world you hear about it what's your
immediate reaction we're well served
that the kids will do great but a lot of
them be killed because the officers are
going to have to learn their job
the officers are poorly trained at the
academy or at OCS are poorly led by the
top generals I mean where's this they're
fine Americans and we should be grateful
that they're willing to be infantry
officers but we don't leave them with
rifle companies or battalions long
enough to learn their trade
it's very hard to run a battalion today
you've got to know a lot about air power
exhibit I'm Betty hundred gotta know a
lot about air power about artillery
about movement of armored vehicles about
how to use infantry it takes a long time
to get good at that
I think it takes at least a year or more
and better three years but instead this
this guy is busy he's got paperwork it's
command of a battalion they may go to a
few field exercises and then a year and
a half is on a different job how old is
that battalion commander nice probably
35 39 so I'm like that depends on his
age major usually a battalion commanders
of Lieutenant Colonel and a company
commanders usually a captain and then a
platoon leader
it's a smallest unit is a lieutenant and
I think the lieutenant's and the
captains and the lieutenant Colonel's
ought to stay in the field longer to get
good at working with troops and a lot of
them love it and we would rather not go
to Charm School and punch their ticket
they would rather stay with the troops
and those guys we want a treasure and
develop and let's stay in their jobs and
a lot of soldiers would like to drive a
truck forever we make them become a
sergeant and a troop leader instead of
letting them drive a truck who thinks
that well first of all have you talked
to the top yes III think I think this
book is everybody who say I laid all
these thoughts on chief of staff of the
Army Carl Boone oh the manpower chief
he's had his say and max Thurman and
they all were interested in my
observations they weren't you know
closed mind about it and they said well
we'll think of it but you know there are
problems you have to get officers ready
to take over these bigger jobs and you
have to give them certain amount of
staff time so I'm not saying it's easy
but I'm saying we've lost the sense of
what's important what's important to me
is winning the next battle if there is
one and making sure our leaders our
middle management the officers and the
sergeants know how to win a small scrap
so that these kids don't have to be
sacrificed while they learn on the job
where are you from originally
New Jersey I used to play basketball
against the firm here to return early
soldiers
at Fort Dix and the army was very
different those days and my older
sisters were not allowed to date
soldiers from Fort Dix it was socially
unacceptable and I'm glad
today's army has soldiers that are
considered acceptable that's how far
we've come and I just regret we're not
leaning toward this new talent enough
where did you go to college I went in
the Navy Air Corps and they sent us to
Georgia Tech for engineering before we
went to flight training but by the time
I got the flight training they did not
need any more pilots so on my own I
abandon engineering which I had to force
feed myself on to get through the Navy
and went to Bucknell University in
Lewisburg Pennsylvania 10-1 then I went
to a series of newspapers New Jersey's
biggest newspaper at the time was the
Newark Evening News and I wanted to come
to Washington so I went to Congressional
quarterly news features which I found in
the yellow pages of the phonebook I
didn't know it existed congressional
quarterly here in town yeah right I'd
going through all the all the
publications I knew about you PAP and
the papers and they had no openings and
I said did I miss anybody and they're
under new services effective
correctional quarterly so they gave me a
beachhead in Washington and taught me
something about the federal government
and then I went to the Washington star
what here went to the Washington star in
1960 the end of the post well no I had a
I had a delay in route as they say in
the army I learned it you have a lot of
fun on newspaper being utility
outfielder infielder pitcher catcher but
you can't make any money and by then I
had a family and I had to get a
specialty became the age of the
specialist when I started out the hero
of the city room was the old front page
rewrite man who could make anything sing
and after work he throw his teeth in his
pocket and get drunk across the street
and it was a different era and I just
got the very last of that era and by the
time I got to Washington you had to be a
specialist so I know learned something
about airplanes so much to Aviation Week
and space technology for five years and
at the end of that five years the post
was looking for someone to take over
military in the space and I was a fit
and I wanted newspapers anyhow so I went
back to what year did you join the
Washington Post 1966 been doing what
you're doing
since then right with the periodical
leaves for good behavior it's the right
books or whatever are you as interested
today as you were in 1966 yeah once I
stopped being interested I think I owe
it to my readers and myself to get out I
don't want to if I lose my curiosity
then it's time to go fishing
we're talking with George Wilson and as
he periodically does he writes a book
this is his latest book you can see her
it's called mud soldier's life inside
the Army the new American army and he is
also author of super care which is was
came out in 1986 and we talked about
super Carey at that time and now we're
talking about the mud soldier in the
army
770 some thousand right and your army
soldiers how many in the Navy that's 600
600 Marine Corps Marine Corps is about
roughly 200,000 and finally the Air
Force it's about 6 667 like that total
numbers at 1.2 million men under arms on
active duty what do you think that'll be
10 years from now with Gorbachev's
direction and barring emergency did you
mean 1.2 or 2.2 no 2.1 is what I meant
I'm sorry you said 1.2 yeah I reverse
the 2.1 million under arms i I think the
Army is going to suffer a cut or enjoy a
cut however you look at it of at least a
hundred thousand in the next eight years
at least given the way the Soviet threat
is diminishing all bets are off if that
changes I think the Air Force will go
down at least 40,000 and if we don't do
something about the prices of weapons
we're going to have to cut more and more
manpower because it's very tempting for
a politician who's trying to get the
spending down to reduce his payroll
because if I fire you today I don't have
to pay you next week if I cancel a
weapon I don't realize those savings for
five years or so and if we let ourselves
buy too many of these stealth bombers
and stealth fighters we're going to
price ourselves out of manpower and I
think there's a balance here that we
have to worry about you really want to
spend up to a billion dollars on one
airplane and have the Air Force tech
turns flying it because there's no money
for anything else we're getting into
this structural disarmament syndrome
where we disarm ourselves by making the
weapons so expensive and some of these
cuts are driven by international events
but some of it very frank frankly are
driven by trying to save money and it's
it's easy to cut manpower and Congress
is doing that Pentagon is doing that so
it's time for a good look at the
our priorities Dick Cheney he's off to a
good start I think he made a mistake by
lambasted the chief of staff the Air
Force in public for going up to the hill
and trying to find the middle ground on
two missiles the MX and the [ __ ] man
which are the residuals on that yes yes
the residuals the professional military
resented that you know it's praise in
public and rebuke in private
and Cheney broke that rule in his first
few weeks in office I know why he might
have done it we want to make a point
that I'm in charge now and nobody's
going to go up there freelancing and
speaking without [ __ ] checking with me
first I mean I can see a manager and
executive trying to take hold the
military but especially since Cheney
never served in the military himself I
think it was a little bit insensitive to
start off that way by bowing out of
force to our Channel what what are the
residuals residuals are the professional
military is more skeptical of this guy
than they would have been otherwise I
think he can win back their confidence
but I think that that was a bad way to
start on the personnel side of this this
Mathia that it's that it's in the
Pentagon I mean they can they can undo
you whether you know it or not whether
you think you've got an order issued but
whether it's carried out or not is
something else again so you need the
confidence of your of your military even
though they all salute obey you have to
establish a rapport there and I think he
will but I think that was a bad way to
start on the budget I think he has got
high marks he actually cut something he
actually cancelled something and story
interesting that the Congress - yeah
v-22 yes 14d the lhx helicopter is that
you know when you it's hard when you're
a civilian you're reading these articles
to know what really matters from your
perspective was did the Marine Corps
need the Osprey it's a nice to have
explain what it is well okay
the Osprey is a advanced aircraft where
it can take off like a helicopter
because you just tilt the propellers of
the plane downward and it pushes the
plane in the air and then when you get
airborne you can
move the propellers up to the wings like
a regular aircraft then it goes forward
so it's a beautiful sounding combination
of taking off like a helicopter and
flying like a real airplane has great
potential for civilian markets I mean
you wouldn't have to have great big
runways in your local airport but it it
it it's taking the Marines to the
poorhouse and a Cadillac it's gonna be a
heavy cost of that bird and I think
Cheney said it's a great airplane and
it'd be nice to have but Congress has
said zero growth in the budget and
something's got to give and we have
helicopters that are new like the Army's
Black Hawk so we'll let the Marines go
from the ship-to-shore on existing
helicopters rather than by this Osprey
which was faster and flew higher and so
forth the Marine said they needed that
to dodge the modern air defenses to get
the Marines from ship to shore so it's a
legitimate argument but and it's a tough
decision it's probably the only it's
probably the reason though Secretary of
Defense's had nerve to make the decision
because it is a close call and you have
a marine lobby that's real but Cheney
decided that we couldn't afford it and
he had the guts to make it and similarly
with the f-14d
you know Grumman desperately is lobbying
to get that fighter plane in production
and he said we just can't have
everything and he cut that and he told
the army that we know your helicopters
are wearing out but not now we don't
have money to get into the lhx in a big
big way and the patchi's going to have
this which is the fire fire attack
helicopter Apaches gonna have to end
earlier than you had plant so he made a
lot of cancellations rather than the
usual stretch out and putting the
problem off to the next guy so I think
that he's off to a promising start that
way but it's just beginning I mean the
match the mismatch between the money in
sight and the Pentagon's five-year plan
is about a hundred and fifty billion
dollars off so we've got a lot of
cutting to do a lot of blood in the
floor a lot of lobbying ahead ninety two
is going to be a horrendous year John
tower told me before he got rejected as
defense secretary he figured he could
finesse 1990 he could fit in s 1991 92
93
you're gonna really see a restructuring
in the defense establishment of this
country what do you think would have
been a difference between a jaunt our
Defense Department and a Dick Cheney
defensible no not an awful lot
I think Tower would have made similarly
tough decisions I think he might have
even cut deeper tower is a real tough
guy and I think he was well suited for
the job at hand which is to restructure
the Pentagon by subtraction after all
these years of addition it's much easier
to restructure by adding on adding on
everybody's happy we start to
restructure by addition everybody's
unhappy and he's mean enough and he
knows where the bodies are buried no
general would roll him who knows what
centers where the where they're coming
from so I think he would have been a
good Secretary of Defense but I don't
think he would start out much
differently than Jamie is we're talking
about the military and the Pentagon and
we're also talking about George Wilson's
new book which is called mud soldier's
life inside the new American army
published by Scribner's right why did
you choose this publisher well they put
out supercarrier and they had a lot of
success with that and they wanted me to
do another book so it just seemed to be
a natural to try it again how do you
write painfully really well it's always
painful because you know anybody who
finishes a book has a salute for me
whether they sell it or not because when
you don't have to get down in the
basement and and write every morning
when you could you know read the paper
or take the dog for a walk or do
something fun it takes a lot of
willpower to go ahead and do it on your
own time but the way I write is I'm I'm
only creative in the morning if I try
and write all day I have to rewrite it
the next day I find that I'm good from
about 5:00 in the morning so noontime
and then I can I can do dunkey work like
make phone calls and do some
proofreading or reading but as far as
writing a narrative and telling a story
and making it adventuresome for the
reader I find I have to be up on my game
and I'm not I'm not very good at night
or at the end of a day and I found it
very hard to write after work for
instance which some guys do
how long did you take to physically
write the book I guess I'd have to say
about six months of the two years I
spent on and how physically how do you
do you write it on a computer or take
part yeah I'm afraid I've been hauled
dragging screaming into the computer age
I have a word processor and I don't
pretend to know all what's inside it I
kind of regard it as a garden hoe I
wanted to take out the weeds and I don't
want to know all the technology whereas
my son is just the opposite he knows
everything about computers and all I
want to do is use it like a advanced
typewriter which I do you send that
product off to the publisher immediately
or your editor or do you read it
yourself no to my surprise I found out
that the publishers at least my
publisher and I think it's true of a
number of others don't want to have to
read a manuscript twice so they'd rather
get the whole thing if they have
confidence you're going to deliver on it
rather than read a part of it and then
have to remember what they had read
before and then go back in so I I put it
in one one final draft that's what they
did
here's that but you dedicated this book
to it's very easy to understand to
American mud soldiers everywhere who
gives so much and asks so little
let's take a look here at some of the
pictures and talk about these people
christian tweety sylvester before and
right next to him as a picture of him
afterward and what what are the two
pictures
this is Tweety in his hometown of
Lincoln California and he had it
terribly unhappy boyhood he and his
stepfather didn't get along he couldn't
seem to discipline himself in high
school he got into drugs he couldn't
keep up his grades he miss school he he
just didn't fit and thought that maybe
you ought to kill himself and then he
thought maybe there's something for me
after all so he tried the armored Bryan
Trotter before and Bryan Trotter
afterwards he's one of the Army's
success stories he was in all kinds of
trouble in his home state of Virginia
his parents and he were at dagger points
and his parents have said the army saved
Brian and Brian
says the army saved me and says if my
country goes to war I want to be out
front let's see here we have another one
a gentleman that looks like he's losing
a little bit it's here where's this yeah
he's already McDaniel as he entered with
hair down on his shoulders at Fort
Benning
and they said okay son you're in the
army you're in basic training and here's
your barber there's only one kind of
haircut so he's he's losing his locks
there much of his regret I didn't pick
the people you picked a feature just
kind of immersed myself in the training
company and pick what I thought would be
a representative number of interesting
characters and also ones that would
typify it's a blacks and some whites
we've got some more pictures here we
here's a drill sergeant
Randy Stover tell us about him well
already Stover is the hit was the hero
of everybody in basic training I have to
remember that Vietnam to these kids who
were 17 and 18 was like World War 1 to
you and me and the war they related to
believe it or not was Grenada Randy
Stover was a rifleman in Grenada he was
a terrific drill sergeant because he did
everything they did and he could do it
all well and he was a coach he's the
kind of coach you want your son to be
under and he was the hero of the kids in
Delta Company at Fort Benning see what
else did guy pick one of those pictures
marking let's see oh there's a good one
right there no no no down here the one
over here right I'm sorry the audience
can't see what we're doing here well I
don't want that one I want up here the
one up above it no right there please
thank you okay that's that's that's
that's that's the drill sergeant that
they nicknamed Z monster his name was
Mario Zuniga and this is what they call
shock treatment it's the first hour in
the United States Army where they report
to their training company and a lot of
kids have been in this reception station
which is like a holding pen until they
get assigned their units and life is
very easy and slack in this reception
center and they get the wrong idea so
the drill sergeants thought it was
incumbent upon them to let them
know that they were in the army and by
god the drill sergeants word was law
so that's ol Z monster shout and it's um
recruit that he can't hear him he can't
hear him speak louder speak louder
what's the purpose of that just to
assert their authority as one drill
sergeant said you know I'm 5 foot 2 I
weigh 130 pounds and I've got it I've
got a boss around these two hundred
pound former football players and some
of them have been and ghetto gangs and I
have to certain my authority from day
one from our one to let them know that
while they're under my command I am the
law now there's some debate as to
whether shock treatment is necessary and
some units are doing away from it but
the feeling of the drill sergeants is
they have to give him a cold shower and
get their attention have they as the
army studied the method of training
where it is deeply but in great depth I
guess the same thing to the point where
they're absolutely sure that they're
going to right way no there's they're
always tinkering with it and my biggest
criticism of their training is that they
overload the drill sergeant to the point
that no man should have to take that
much load of working you know 14 16
hours a day six days a week I don't
think you can maintain your patience
with that heavier workload I think we
ought to put and put a little more help
in there with the drill sergeant either
more drill sergeants or perhaps put in a
first lieutenant with some combat
experience that would be my first
recommendation to help them run these
training companies although the drill
sergeants would resent that the other
thing is I think it's time for a look at
how long it takes to learn something
these this manual is you know it takes
so many hours to learn how to plan a
claymore mine in the ground or throw a
grenade I think these kids are so smart
that we ought to go right into more of
this fun action more this Rambo stuff
where you teach them how to go through
the woods and take out a sniper and I
just love that and it's terrific
training and make make it more fun by
putting some grenade ranges out in the
back of the barracks and have contests
and use the plastic replicas of any tank
weapons rethink the whole regime of we
got bright kids they want to learn
give it to them instead of just making
them stand out there in the grandstand
or sit down the grandstand hour after
hour here's some guy drawn away at you
know how to how to work that play bore
claim or mine or you know how to take
apart your weapon it's too boring right
now they ought to make it more
interesting can't you just hear the
viewer in the audience who is a veteran
of the service saying he's got to be
crazy make it more fun this is serious
business
well you join the imagery and you want
to be a Rambo you're doing it for
excitement part of part of excitement
it's it it's fun to be in a mock combat
situation with your buddies you're the
sniper and I'm the guy coming through
the woods trying to wipe you out that
that's a game and maybe it sounds
immature but combat is you do in combat
what you learn in training and I would
like to see us have more of this in the
field in the woods actual exercises so
the kids get really confident know how
to communicate with each other rather
than so much of the sitting in the
grandstand and listening you open this
book up think it was the big red one the
battle writing 6666 why well I was at
Fort Riley and I read the citation of
this sergeant Robinson James Robinson
and he won the medal of honor for his
activity in this battle I had never
heard about even though I'd been a
combat reporter in Vietnam twice
66 and 72 and I said that must have been
some battle and better than that this
Robinson was a member of the same
Charlie Company I was following through
so I thought why not make the connection
between this is what these kids on with
would have to do in combat and this is
what they're like today so the way to do
that for the book purposes was to look
up the survivors of this ferocious
battle the Charlie Company fought in 66
where they were surrounded by a whole
Vietcong battalion and describe what
really happens in actual combat and then
ask the question to
reader who would volunteer to go out
there and get shot at like that and
experienced that horror how many people
were killed in this battle in 66
there was about there was 80% casualty
of wounded and killed I think was 34
killed out of a company 134 heavy heavy
heavy amount of machine guns were fired
in on their narrowing perimeter okay
we've got some other picture we'll get
to in just a second but what happened to
the people have you talked to any of the
people in the in the Vietnam in that
battle in Vietnam right this is Johnny
libs who I looked up he was he he led
the battle because the company commander
was wounded early on and he was the hero
of the battle in the sense that he saved
what he could of the company by calling
in artillery so close to the perimeter
that the Vietcong every time they masked
for the final assault were broken up by
the artillery that Johnny kept calling
in and he and his few survivors were all
in this very tight circle firing outward
and they were up against about eight
machine guns all slicing up their
company they are up against snipers and
the trees that were shooting people in
the back as they were laying in the
ground it was just a nightmare of an
operation where is he today Johnny lives
is in Evansville Indiana and he runs a
candy company there and he and his
fellow survivors have said that talking
out this battle for the purposes of the
book have made them well again because
they could finally get over their guilt
now that they have it in perspective
here's a Congressional Medal of Honor
one that's Jimmy Robinson he's the one
who inspired me to reconstruct the
battle by going from me his roll up to
everyone else I could find hillel I know
he he died charging a 50 caliber
machine-gun nest almost cut him in half
how do you find out what his story is
today where'd you go well I went to the
army history sources I talked to his
family to find out what kind of a boy he
was and there was quite a lot of
official records on that pad on his roll
when the young fellows come in today
into Charlie Company did they know the
history
it is the history on the wall somewhere
in the barracks well the that picture
and the citation is on the on the wall
but again I think we could do a little
better by instilling these kids with a
sense of their regiment and the company
and the tradition and we do some of that
in the Army today but I think we should
do more who's this that's Phil Hall he
was the machine gunner in the battle and
he was very anxious to have the story of
their heroism told and he never could
get anybody interested in the army to
reconstruct what had happened and he's
been very generous to me because I took
an interest in his role and everybody
else's and he's visiting the Vietnam
Memorial there in Washington looking up
the names of the guys who did not
survive that very same battle are you
surprised when you go down into that
memorial almost any day and see as many
people as you do yes I'm surprised and
I'm always emotionally struck we're
almost a knockout punch when I read some
of the messages that they leave at the
wall it's almost like the wall in
Jerusalem where you see Jewish people
saying their prayers and then leaving a
message in the cracks of the wall this
this Vietnam wall has become to one
generation anyhow like the the Great
Wall in Jerusalem is to religious Jews
here's tweety again with his mother this
time how important is the family
relationships for these young soldiers
well there's usually somebody who keeps
keeps these kids who haven't found their
way in society afloat and in this case
Tweety's mother was his heroine and she
kept encouraging him and then he missed
her so much he went in the army but of
course he couldn't admit it so this is
the first time that he reunions with her
at the end of basic training and usually
there's some member of the family not
always the parents who inspire these
kids to the point they at least try and
make something themselves by joining the
army who's this gentleman that's captain
Jim Fleener he's a Kentuckian and proud
of it and who's my idea of a
a good officer he's a teacher he's a
human being the men just worshipped him
as a role model and most of all he cared
about his men and they could tell once
the once the troops since that you care
about them they'll do anything for you
they'll walk through fire and somehow he
projected that and it was a very happy
company at Fort Benning how do you
convince someone in the military that
you care about them especially in the
middle of basic training I think it's
hard to fake either you do or you don't
and and if you don't really care about
these kids you're just doing it to
advance your career they have the the
best manure separator in the world they
sense this immediately and the word goes
that this guy doesn't care about us
I think mochou most officers do care but
they have to express it a little more
readily and dramatically by asking about
the kids and once in a while having a
barbecue for the families of the company
to make it more of an army family
theoretically the army is all for that
unfortunately the training schedule and
filling all the blocks gets in the way
and very often it doesn't get done for
instance a young wife at Fort Riley had
never met the company commander that her
husband has served under for almost a
year well that's not the way it's
supposed to work you're supposed to have
some sense of identity with your army if
you're a young army wife volunteer army
we're gonna have it for a while we'll
never go back to the draft we'll have to
go back to the draft if we ever get in a
major war because we're kidding
ourselves that an army of seven hundred
thousand-plus is enough to fight
anywhere so these kids are going to hold
the line until the draft can produce the
replacements we'll go back to the draft
only I think if we have a national
emergency
I think the volunteer army is here to
stay in one form or the other we're just
gonna look at a series of pictures you
have here about our new soldiers anybody
on here that you particularly remember
more than others well they're all kind
of interesting here here this this right
here on a tostone all right that's Glenn
Dow you
in Maine from Maine he got bored being a
carpenter he thought he could be more by
joining the army and he did so he
resented the amount of time they wasted
when he was at Fort Riley he wanted to
be more than he could be and they didn't
lean his way enough and this fellow
that's spanked Barker he joined the army
because he was working in a restaurant
in California he was bored he saw no
future he had a wife he thought that he
could make something of himself as he
told me I wanted to be something more
than the little fat kid thing in the
army yet overweight kind of
self-conscious about himself he gained a
lot of traction and he's just finished
reading listening going down the page
mark I see who else write below
mr. Barker who's that gentleman that
Aaron Henson Aaron Henson he's from
Texas he had a daughter he had tried to
be a fireman in his hometown of Texas
and the white establishment made excuses
of why he couldn't join the fire
department even after he had passed the
test he got kind of embittered because
he didn't really get smacked in the face
with prejudice until he became 18 then
he decided that the army offered a
chance for him to discipline himself and
to make something himself and make his
daughter proud of him and he had a very
rough beginning he tried to kill himself
at one point because he just couldn't
adjust to army life but then he became
it an outstanding soldier and he's doing
well in Germany at this moment Kevin
Britton
Kevin Bruton same kind of story he was
getting nowheres in Alabama he thought
that he was falling into bad habits and
maybe the army would straighten him out
and make a man of him and as far as I
can tell he's doing well right below him
Patrick I can't see ya he's doing well
is it Victor that Dickerson yeah yeah he
joined the army because for the
adventure we want have some fun and he
took the army life and as far as I know
he's still doing well he did not go into
Riley with me he went somewhere else
arrey guys at harbor right can't see ya
in there her yeah he's a mud soldier who
thought that the army offered better
prospects than he could find around home
and last I talked to him he was glad
that he had done it disciplined himself
but but here again he's wondering
whether they're teaching him something
he can use once it gets out of the Army
is there you've been around the Pentagon
for a lot of years yeah too many
probably is there a favorite service
inside the Pentagon that you know how to
ask that but I mean is there a service
that people would defer to over the
others in the and they'd rather have the
Navy involved in a conflict with the
Marines then they would the army the Air
Force is there any kind of favoritism
that you see from the top down well I'm
more worried about just the opposite it
seems like we can't do anything anymore
without making all four services have a
role in for instance there was no reason
that you couldn't have had just the Navy
and the Marines do Grenada there was no
reason in my view to have f-111s join
the Navy planes to bomb Libya but we've
gotten the syndrome now where it's got
to be a for service show so the Air
Force has to have a piece of the action
take the highly secret to attempt to
rescue the hostages from Iran in 1980 we
had to have marine pilots go from the
Navy aircraft care and we had to have
the Air Force involved in the c-130 and
the refueling and we had to have the
army as part of the troops so it's just
the opposite we've got this jointness
syndrome where a military man is
supposed to learn something about all
the services which is okay but then
willing to go on a combat operation
we've seen compelled to give every
service a piece of the action I think we
ought to get away from that the book is
called mud soldier's life inside the new
American army our author is George C
Wilson who is a military correspondent
for the Washington Post thank you very
much thank you